Traduttore: Giulia Claudi
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
La luce, da dove viene la luce?
Tutta la luce che abbiamo attorno a noi,
anche quella che viene
da questi oggetti illuminati
viene dal cielo.
In un modo o nell'altro ci ha raggiunto,
magari tempo fa, dal cielo.
La luce viene solamente dal cosmo.
Da quale cosmo? Da quello che ci circonda.
Da questo cielo, che non possiamo
vedere da questa città.
Bergamo non può vedere questo cielo,
questo cielo si vede solamente in Africa.
Si vede quando è buio, quando la città
non illumina il cielo di notte.
Se vi capita di andare nel sud del mondo,
vedete questo cielo.
Bene, immaginiamoci di essere
qualche tempo fa,
Due milioni e mezzo di anni fa.
Ci sarà pur stato un primo momento
in cui un ominide nella fase evolutiva
abbia alzato gli occhi da terra
e abbia realizzato che cosa aveva
sopra la sua testa.
Immaginatevi quell'istante,
un istante importante della nostra storia
che va remota nei tempi lontanissimi.
Da quel momento in poi, l'uomo ha sempre
avuto con sé nella sua cultura
la coscienza dell'universo
e della luce che ci arriva dal cielo.
Facciamo un grande salto.
Questo profilo lo conoscete benissimo.
È il profilo di Stonehenge.
Cos'è Stonehenge?
È una realizzazione
di un popolo primitivo.
Siamo a 4,500 anni fa,
quindi praticamente
siamo prima della Storia.
È uno degli esempi di come lo studio,
l'osservazione del cielo,
abbia plasmato la cultura dell'umanità.
Per fare questo particolare
sistema costruttivo,
quella popolazione antica
ha fatto uno sforzo immenso
ha portato dei massi pesantissimi
da decine, forse centinaia
di km di distanza,
per strutturarli in una struttura
circolare di grandissime dimensioni.
Per quale motivo?
Per far guardare le stelle.
Per vedere il moto dei pianeti,
per capire quando seminare,
quando raccogliere.
Per fare dei riti legati alle mitologie,
legati appunto alle informazioni
che venivano dal cielo.
Il cielo ha sempre plasmato la cultura:
maia, egizia e tutta
la storia dell'umanità
e, secondo questo esempio,
usando la tecnologia,
le caratteristiche
più avanzate dell'epoca.
Facciamo un altro salto, di 2,300 anni.
Siamo nel Mediterraneo,
una nave greco-romana
trasporta del materiale
tra la Grecia e l'Italia
e affonda davanti all'isola di Kythera,
un'isola del Peloponneso.
Nel 1906, all'inizio del secolo scorso,
questo relitto viene trovato
e raccogliendo il materiale
trovato nel relitto,
nella stiva di una nave vecchia 2,200 anni
a quel punto, a parte le solite anfore,
si trovano delle strutture come questa,
delle specie di rotelle
completamente coperte di calcare,
che vengono portate al museo di Atene
e lasciate lì per 60 anni.
Non si sa cosa fossero.
60 anni dopo fanno
le radiografie con i raggi x
e scoprono all'interno di queste rotelle
degli ingranaggi sottilissimi
tipo gli orologi del 1600,
ma siamo nel 200 a.C.
Questo è una sorta di astrolabio,
un sistema che permetteva
ai potenti di allora
di calcolarsi il moto dei pianeti,
soprattutto le eclissi di sole e di luna.
Immaginatevi cosa vuol dire
per un generale, o per un politico,
sapere quando il sole sta per scomparire,
quando la luna sta per essere oscurata.
Una tecnologia
incredibilmente sofisticata.
Cicerone ci racconta
che c'erano due di queste macchine,
a quel tempo disponibili,
nell'allora civiltà greco-romana.
Una l'abbiamo ritrovata in fondo al mare,
una fortuna straordinaria.
Un altro esempio di come la tecnologia,
la più sofisticata,
fosse stata messa a disposizione,
per che cosa?
Studiare, prevedere, capire il cielo.
Facciamo un altro salto.
Questa è una pagina dell'Almagesto.
L'Almagesto era una sorta di Treccani,
di Enciclopedia Britannica,
in cui era raccolta
tutta l'informazione nota all'umanità
nei mille anni che sono intercorsi
fra la fine dell'impero romano
e la metà del primo millennio.
Come potete vedere da queste immagini,
la Terra è perfettamente formata
ha tutti i continenti, l'America del Nord,
del Sud, perfino l'Australia.
Qual è il problema? È al centro del mondo.
Tutte quante le sfere celesti
la circondano.
Quella che trasporta il sole,
quella che trasporta la luna,
i vari pianeti, via via fino alla sfera
che porta alle stelle fisse.
Infatti siamo nel 1550,
l'America è scoperta da Colombo nel 1492,
ma non c'è ancora la comprensione
di dov'è questo pianeta
all'interno dell'universo.
Infatti occorre aspettare il 1609,
quando Galileo,
con questo piccolo cannocchiale
che oggi comprate dalla Lidl per 50€,
capì che c'erano dei satelliti
che giravano intorno a un pianeta, Giove,
e che stavano perforando,
stavano rovinando,
stavano distruggendo
l'armonia delle sfere celesti.
Finalmente la Terra trovò
il suo posto nell'Universo.
Non era che il Sole
girava intorno alla Terra,
ma la Terra attorno al Sole.
Il cannocchiale,
la tecnologia del momento,
attualmente, lo sviluppo tecnologico
ha portato a dei progressi straordinari.
Questo è un cannocchiale
del secolo scorso,
è il cannocchiale con cui Hubble
guardò a lungo la nostra galassia
prese delle immagini
del nostro insieme di stelle,
che si pensava allora
che fosse tutto l'universo
e studiando alcune piccole stelle,
un po' sfocate
capì da una notte all'altra,
che erano altre galassie,
molto, molto lontane.
Da una notte all'altra
l'universo si espanse
di un fattore più di mille
e da allora abbiamo continuato
ad espanderlo,
fino ad arrivare, praticamente,
alle sue origini.
Questo con un telescopio chiaramente
molto più potente di quello di Galileo.
Oggi abbiamo nello spazio
il telescopio dei telescopi:
il telescopio di Hubble,
che guarda l'universo
usando le condizioni
straordinariamente favorevoli
di potere fare
le osservazioni dallo spazio
e questa immagine che vedete sulla destra
è una capocchia di spillo
del cosmo sulla nostra testa
ingrandita in una quantità enorme
di volte da Hubble
e vediamo le prime galassie,
le prime protostelle,
vediamo un universo
di miliardi e miliardi di anni fa.
Dicevo che la tecnologia è fondamentale
per capire l'universo attorno a noi
ma vedrete com'è sorprendente la velocità
con cui la tecnologia è evoluta
in quest'ultimo secolo.
Il secolo che è passato ci ha permesso
di fare dei progressi molto più grandi
che in millenni e in milioni di anni
che ci hanno anticipato.
Vedete questa immagine,
siamo alla cappella degli Scrovegni
e vediamo come Giotto nel 1301
dipingesse una bellissima serie di pitture
fra cui la natività e si può apprezzare
la bellezza di questa pittura
perché vediamo la forma,
le immagini delle persone,
gli animali, una prospettiva della capanna
ma sopra la capanna vediamo
una brutta stella cometa
una sorta di palloccola rossastra
e ci domandiamo come mai
un grande pittore come Giotto
avesse disegnato
una stella cometa così brutta.
Perché l'aveva vista nel cielo,
perché vedeva in quell'istante
quella stella passare sulla sua testa.
È la cometa di Halley,
che passa ogni 76 anni
e nel 1301 passava sulla testa
di questo pittore
che l'ha copiata fedelmente.
Infatti queste foto del 1910,
le prime foto di questa cometa,
ci mostrano una struttura
del tutto analoga
a quella che Giotto dipingeva nel 1300.
E nel 1986, 76 anni dopo,
l'uomo era in grado
di fare i suoi satelliti artificiali
i suoi robot telecomandati
che sono andati letteralmente
a pizzicare la coda della cometa di Giotto
per vedere come è fatta.
600 anni per passare dall'occhio
alla fotografia,
76 anni per passare dalla fotografia
alla capacità di raggiungere
la cometa di Halley.
Tecnologia, tecnologia.
Questi signori sono Penzias e Wilson,
due ingegneri diventati famosi
perché hanno sostanzialmente pubblicato
un articolo dicendo:
abbiamo cercato di fare
uno strumento elettronico
di bassissimo rumore ambientale
che praticamente dovesse misurare
nessun tipo di rumore
e sentiamo un rumore
continuo, assordante,
che viene da tutte le parti dell'universo.
Questo ha un suo orecchio,
che è un'antenna, una sorta
di grande antenna radio,
che gli ha permesso di capire
che il loro rumore veniva dappertutto.
Non sapevano che cosa avevano trovato,
hanno pubblicato questo risultato
e poche settimane dopo,
altri hanno interpretato
che loro stavano ascoltando
l'eco del Big Bang
e hanno avuto il premio Nobel per questo.
Un rumore che di fatto è l'eco
della grande esplosione iniziale.
Oggi questo tipo di studi si fanno
con strumenti molto più potenti.
Questo pallone stratosferico
ha studiato quell'eco del Big Bang
capendo che è strutturato
in un modo molto particolare.
Se voi mettete gli occhiali
per guardare il Big Bang
sono una specie di occhiali google
un po' particolari,
che fanno gli scienziati
che studiano queste cose
e uscite fuori a guardare il cielo,
lo vedreste butterato,
come se avesse il morbillo.
Quel morbillo è il dettaglio
dell'esplosione legata al Big Bang,
visto 300 mila anni dopo.
E forse voi avete visto
un'immagine come questa
nelle prime pagine
dei principali quotidiani
un satellite chiamato Planck
ha completato questa immagine
del cielo col morbillo,
col morbillo del Big Bang,
è un cielo, appunto,
che si è rivelato 280 mila anni,
300 mila anni dopo il Big Bang.
Ma recentemente sui giornali
avete sentito questa cosa incredibile,
che uno strumento posto al Polo Sud
ha fatto ancora di più.
Ha trovato in questa immagine
di 300 mila anni
una traccia di qualche cosa che è successo
1 miliardesimo di secondo
dopo l'esplosione iniziale.
Questi cerchi della luce
polarizzata nel cielo
ci stanno raccontando cosa è successo
proprio all'inizio dei tempi.
Tecnologia. Ma che cosa è successo
negli ultimi 50 anni?
Una grandissima rivoluzione.
Abbiamo imparato a guardare
i colori dell'universo
che non sono visibili all'occhio umano
e soprattutto
non sono visibili dalla Terra.
L'universo che ha visto Galileo,
Hubble, con i telescopi,
ci manda quella luce
che passa nell'atmosfera.
Questa luce è una luce visibile
che attraversa bene l'aria.
Le onde radio viste da Penzias e Wilson,
sono come quelle dei telefonini,
passano bene attraverso l'aria.
Ma ci sono moltissime altre onde
che non riescono
a passare attraverso l'aria,
per vedere le quali dobbiamo uscire,
letteralmente, dall'atmosfera.
In questi ultimi 50 anni siamo riusciti
a fare questo sistematicamente
e siamo riusciti ad avere tutti i colori
di un universo altrimenti invisibile.
Per esempio questa immagine che voi vedete
se andiamo sul visibile
è l'universo, la Via Lattea, che domina
il punto di vista, visto dalla Terra,
vista con gli occhi del primo ominide,
con gli occhi di Galileo, di Hubble,
nel visibile.
Ha una certa struttura,
chiaramente non riusciamo
a vederla tutta quanta,
ma ha queste caratteristiche.
Se andiamo nell'infrarosso,
che è una frequenza
che non passa attraverso l'atmosfera,
vediamo una figura completamente diversa.
Se andiamo nelle microonde,
che sono quelle del forno a microonde
che abbiamo in cucina,
di nuovo cambia completamente.
Se andiamo nel radio, che è quello
che si riesce a vedere anche dalla Terra
con le misure di Penzias e Wilson,
cambia di nuovo;
dei grandi insiemi di gas freddo
che appaiono ed emettono
quel tipo di luce radio.
Se andiamo nell'ultravioletto,
che è un colore che non passa
facilmente l'atmosfera,
nascono tutta una serie di stelle
altrimenti invisibili nel visibile.
Nei raggi x, cambia di nuovo
il nostro universo,
appare completamente diverso
con delle sorgenti caldissime.
Per andare a finire ai raggi gamma,
che sono quelle delle esplosioni nucleari,
esistono degli oggetti
che esplodono tipo nucleare
senza sosta, da milioni e milioni di anni.
Questo è l'universo che oggi
noi abbiamo davanti agli occhi
un universo pieno di colori,
che 50 anni fa non conoscevamo.
Questa è la parte di universo invisibile
che è diventato visibile,
che si è disvelato negli ultimi 50 anni,
grazie al lavoro di persone
come Riccardo Giacconi
un italiano che ha avuto il Nobel nel 2002
perché ha scoperto l'universo
fatto di sorgenti di raggi x,
nessuno ci credeva,
"Non fare questo esperimento."
Lui insistette cocciutamente,
andò in America
costruì questo satellite,
lo mise in orbita
e vide le prime sorgenti di raggi x.
Oppure questo satellite
che si chiama Fermi,
in onore del nostro grande fisico
degli anni '40-'50,
che letteralmente osserva
l'universo caldissimo
in continua esplosione nucleare.
Oppure questi strumenti ancora più moderni
che si chiamano strumenti a luce Cherenkov
che guardano della luce
di un colore così estremo
che non siamo nemmeno in grado
di produrla nei nostri laboratori
un'energia spaventosamente alta
che viene prodotta in alcuni casi
dalle sorgenti, dei mostri di energia,
che sono in alcune parti
del nostro universo.
Questo vi spiega un pochettino
perché in orbita abbiamo tanti satelliti,
ciascuno sono occhi
che guardano in colori diversi
che guardano a distanze diverse,
che guardano vicino o così lontano
da toccare i bordi dell'universo visibile,
da arrivare fino a toccare il Big Bang.
E oggi abbiamo quindi
queste meravigliose immagini
della Via Lattea, ma anche dell'universo,
in tutti i colori possibili immaginabili.
Questo è il nostro universo,
diventato visibile negli ultimi 60 anni,
prima il 90% era
completamente irraggiungibile.
Abbiamo finito, abbiamo raggiunto
il compimento della scienza?
Abbiamo raggiunto i limiti
dell'osservabile?
No.
Non conosciamo ancora davvero
quello che è il vero universo oscuro.
C'è un universo che è talmente oscuro
che non riesce neanche ad emettere la luce
non solamente la luce che emette
non passa dall'atmosfera.
C'è un universo che è sostanzialmente
invisibile a qualsiasi forma di luce.
E quindi abbiamo imparato recentemente,
negli ultimi 50 anni,
tante cose riguardanti l'universo.
Sappiamo che è piatto, omogeneo,
isotropo, è composto da radiazione,
da materia, da protoni,
da neutroni, come noi,
ma sappiamo che è solamente
il 4% del totale.
Esiste una componente,
che si chiama materia oscura,
che sappiamo essere il 23%,
sei volte più abbondante
della materia normale
ed è in questa stanza, ci attraversa,
ma non riusciamo a vederla.
Non solo, abbiamo capito
che c'è un altro 73%,
che è energia nascosta nel vuoto,
di cui non sappiamo assolutamente niente
se non che esiste.
E tra le altre cose,
l'antimateria primordiale
che rappresenta il Big Bang
se n'è andata e non sappiamo
che fine ha fatto.
Per cui abbiamo imparato
a guardare tutti i colori dell'universo
ma mentre facevamo questo,
abbiamo scoperto che c'è
un 95% di universo,
che è letteralmente
presente, ma invisibile,
con tutte le tecniche
che noi abbiamo potuto inventare
in questi ultimi 50 anni.
Per cui sappiamo di non sapere,
non siamo mai stati così ignoranti
in modo cosciente,
relativamente alla natura.
Quindi, dopo un secolo
di straordinaria crescita
dopo una tecnologia
che è letteralmente esplosa
e ci ha aperto
tutti i colori dell'universo,
siamo arrivati ad un nuovo bordo,
a un nuovo confine,
sappiamo che il 95% di ciò che ci circonda
dev'essere ancora scoperto.
E quindi siamo alle soglie
di un nuovo millennio
in cui ci rimane da scoprire
la maggior parte delle cose
che ci circondano.
E quindi il mio pensiero
per questa chiacchierata di TEDx è:
"AAA. Sappiamo che il 95% dell'universo
è assolutamente invisibile.
Si cercano idee
per capire di cosa sia fatto."
Grazie.
(Applausi)